én azt látom hogy például a nyugdíjasok
körében a az
átverések hihetetlen mértéket öltenek
amikor megkeresik a
nyugdíjasokat mindenféle indokkal
vagy hogy hogy köldjenek pénzt mert az
unokájuk nagy bajban van és hogy vag
akár most már hang és videós bocsánat
hang és képtartalmat lehet generálni
ezzel és és a a a az idősebb korosztály
aki nincs felkészülve erre a fajta
személyes támadásra úgymond nagyon tehát
emlékszem az egyik ismerősöm a bankba
dolgozott és mondta hogy ő így
könyörgött hogy ne küldje el azt a pénzt
mert valamelyik filöpszigeteken
valamelyik szerelme akivel az interneten
találkozott szüksége van ahhoz hogy át
tudjon utazni egyik városból a másikó és
mondta hogy ne ne küldje kéri szépen
tudja ez átverés és és nem lehetett
lebeszélni róla